Doctor Doom kills Spider-Man 100 times
and I'm not even lying this story's
gonna blow your mind so this story
basically opens up with the
assassination of Doctor Doom he's
literally shot outside of the United
Nations as a representative of latviria
now of course Spider-Man ever in the
wrong place at the wrong time comes
across the corpse while all the lap
Varian security guards are trying to
keep everybody at Bay and Peter Parker
is like oh it's cool guys it's cool just
let me take a look and then he rips his
head off and basically reveals that it's
a doombot it's not actually Doctor Doom
those of you guys who don't know what
that means Doctor Doom very rarely ever
actually appears it's usually just a
doombot a robot version of Doctor Doom
This Time It's Different because as soon
as this doombot's head is ripped off
it's considered a desecration literally
Spider-Man desecrated the corpse of
Doctor Doom which is hilarious for me to
say out loud so the Doom bot effectively
manifests and then that's when
everything Breaks Loose because
following that Miguel O'Hara shows up
out of nowhere why because it's Miguel
O'Hara he's always incapable of getting
back to his own timeline this guy
couldn't get back to his own Universe if
all he had to do was walk three feet
that way you know what I mean he could
just never get back home but in all
reality basically the future is in a
state of disarray timelines are being
disrupted all kinds of crazy things and
so Miguel's trying to get back the
problem with this is that things pop off
from Miguel O'Hara and he literally
disappears from existence but before
that happens he gives Spider-Man his
holographic device this actually
contains Lila and it's basically Miguel
O'Hara's ability to figure out what he
should do in any particular circumstance
when he's in the future one part because
the technology is there and two because
he's just not as smart as Peter Parker
let's just be honest with ourselves but
when he effectively vanishes and
disappears now it's really just Peter
just kind of left to his own devices to
figure out how in the world he's going
to cope with this now gigantic Doctor
Doom that is basically Unleashed an
entire horde of doombots on the city of
New York for no other reason than the
fact that somebody tried to assassinate
this guy and Spider-Man ripped off his
head it's basically just downright
Vengeance and anger and in fact he
demands Justice from everybody and so
what he basically says here is I want
the person who shot me brought to me
right now or the entirety of this city
is going to suffer and Dr Doom will do
it too he will raise an entire city over
small things Marvel's full of characters
like that now the kicker about all this
is that with all these Doom bots out
there wreaking havoc throughout the
entirety of the city that there isn't
really anybody that's available to come
to the aid of Spider-Man except for the
one person that you would suspect the
least Spider-Man sister Teresa what
Spider-Man has a sister yep in Marvel
Comics he does I bet you didn't know
that time for an origin video so the
thing about this is that when Teresa
shows up here one she's every bit as
capable as Spider-Man is but two she
even tells him I know exactly who it was
to try to be assassinate him and I know
exactly where to go that's when we
switch over to the chameleon now the
chameleon is a classic villain in
Spider-Man comics and in fact if I
remember correctly he was the first
villain that Spider-Man ever faced off
against in his own Comics but the reason
why this assassination even took place
in the first place or at least this
attempt was due to the fact that the
country of sankaria which borders
latviria to the South was basically
trying to instigate a scenario where Dr
Doom would effectively be locked up
which they actually achieved when they
nuked the Moon that was a crazy moment
in Marvel Comics but what ends up
happening here is Countess karkov who's
basically the leader of laviria to a
degree effectively tells chameleon just
so you know uh lavirian security forces
are coming your way because I basically
gave them your location right literally
ratted him out because you know she's a
villain and that's what villains do so
this leads to Spider-Man and Teresa just
busting into the place which is
absolutely amazing and then Teresa pulls
a gun and she goes to shoot chameleon
why well because she doesn't really have
any reservations when it comes to
killing people plus she's also got a
vendetta against him and that actually
goes into her origin story which if you
guys are interested we will cover later
on this week but what we end up finding
out in terms of this Revelation is that
it wasn't actually chameleon who killed
or at least who shot Doctor Doom don't
worry we're gonna get to the part where
he kills Spider-Man 100 ways not gonna
leave you hanging it's not click bait so
instead what the chameleon had done is
he had contracted out to a guy known as
The Hitman who actually had this genius
idea of always backing up his psyche so
whenever it was that he would commit a
hit he would basically off himself and
then his mind would be downloaded into a
new body so he always had an Escape Plan
pretty ingenious to be quite honest with
you guys but once they start to realize
the gravity of the situation which is to
say Doctor Doom is demanding the body of
the person who tried to assassinate him
and that person is effectively dead
Spider-Man breaks out the holographic
device and then in turn enters it and
what he does he starts talking to Lila
and she basically spills the beans right
I can provide you with any number of
circumstances where you can see any
number of possibilities come to fruition
so in turn he starts coming up with all
these different ideas on how he can
neutralize the threat of Doctor Doom now
the first thing they do right the first
idea that Spider-Man has is a terrible
idea but the first idea he has is to use
the chameleon to have him change into
one of the latvirian security forces and
then in turn he shows up to Dr Doom with
the body of Hitman saying we found the
man who tried to assassinate you Doctor
Doom you can call off your attack Dr
Doom takes one look at that and he's
just like fools did you really believe
you could trick me with a simple ruse
which makes perfect sense right anybody
who knows anything about Dr Doom will
tell you this guy's magic is second to
none he's every bit as capable as Doctor
Strange and depending on the
circumstance even more powerful so
you're not going to trick this guy with
like a body double and literally Teresa
is like I told you this wasn't gonna
work and chameleon is like man I told
you too bro but like Spider-Man's like I
thought it was worth a shot and so in
response Doctor Doom incinerates
everybody which includes Spider-Man well
he doesn't initially die instead
Teresa's killed Spider-Man kind of
survives it to a degree and then he
speaks to Doctor Doom for a second and
then Dr Doom just completely incinerates
him down to the bone right go to
scenario number two the next scenario is
Spider-Man basically handing over
chameleon and it still doesn't make a
difference Dr Doom incinerates
Spider-Man and the entire city of New
York anyway Spider-Man then goes to the
next scenario which is bringing together
all the Avengers and they still lose
Spider-Man even dawn times this just
legit Spider-Man armor and he still gets
destroyed he tries time travel and he
still dies he makes a deal with Mephisto
which you think he know better after the
events of Spider-Man one more day I know
all you guys who hate that story are
feeling this and it still doesn't work
right like every single circumstance no
matter what happens Spider-Man and
everybody else get destroyed by Doctor
Doom in fact because of the deal that
Peter Parker had made with Mephisto
basically both he and Doctor Doom end up
trapped in hell for all eternity so what
he ends up doing here is he comes up
with this just crazy concocted plan
right this crazy idea that according to
Lila has a 38 chance of success it's not
going to work the answer here is to just
tell Dr Doom the truth literally just
tell him what happened and so Peter
Parker shows up to Dr Doom and Dr Doom
smacks Peter Parker around just kind of
beats up a little bit really for no
other reason than the fact that Peter is
just inconvenienced him which is is
reason enough to probably get beat up by
Doctor Doom but as he's got him in this
Chokehold and as he's about to kill him
Peter spills the beans and says look all
these cameras and everything that are
here this is a trap it's a ruse the
whole goal here is to get you to enact
some extreme level of violence so the
entire world will come crashing down on
you you'll be tossed in prison latviria
will be leaderless and some karya can
literally take over your country and so
when Doctor Doom asks him is this some
kind of a Rouge is it some kind of
nonsense the response of Peter is no
this is not a lie I'm 100 telling you
the truth and so following that Dr Doom
starts to withdraw his various doombots
but not before Doctor Doom just out of
spite starts just attacking things in
the city of New York right he attacks
the library Hells Bells man he even blew
up the Statue of Liberty just going
after all these small little landmarks
and just just raising the place right
just to illustrate what happens when you
inconvenience doctor do even Peter
Parker tries to step in and say no you
can't do this Dr Doom of course blasts
him and says silence Doom answers to no
man which is an accurate statement but
following that Doom basically gets the
revelation of what's actually happening
here what's really cool about this is
that this dovetails nicely into the
story where basically some karya nukes
the moon and then blames it on Doctor
Doom and if you want to know about that
story click this link here in the video
with that being said guys we're going to
bring this to an end thank you all for
watching and I will catch you all later
peace